[Musique]
dans sa dernière allocution monsieur le
président de la république a annoncé
pour le 11 mai la réouverture des
établissements scolaires
depuis cette annonce au gouvernement
réfléchit à la méthode avec laquelle
pourrait se faire opérer ce retour
cependant de nombreuses questions
restent en suspens les interrogations
niveau sanitaire tout d'abord toutes les
conditions seront elles remplies pour
organiser l'accueil des élèves des
enseignants du personnel avec le maximum
de sécurité l'utilisation des masques
sera t'elle requise des tests seront ils
réaliser et si oui selon quelles
modalités
comment faire respecter les gestes
barrière la distanciation sociale par
les élèves du primaire qui sont les
moins enclins à les pratiquer et qui
pourtant devrait rentrer les premières
un lien en français de la vente en ligne
met en vente avec votre accord 60
millions de masques chirurgicaux pour
les entreprises alors que vous n'avez
toujours pas répondu clairement aux
pharmaciens dont c'est pourtant le
métier qui vous interpellent pour savoir
s'ils peuvent ou non vendre à prix
coûtant des masques aux tissus ou
chirurgicaux avec mes collègues les
républicains nous réclamons depuis de
longues semaines d'annoncé sans délai
une annulation totale des charges
fiscales et sociales des cafés commerces
restaurants hôtels et de toutes les
entreprises gravement impacté par la
crise que nous traversons
seule cette annulation pure et simple
permettra la reprise et sera de nature à
sauver des milliers d'emplois les
banlieues flambent à nouveau
monsieur le ministre nos forces de
l'ordre sont mises en cause sont
attaqués quasiment 1 et donc nous sommes
pour ne pas faire de stigmatisation un
peu un peu discret un exemple concret un
un homme de 30 ans condamné 14 x qui a
attaqué les forces de l'ordre forces de
l'ordre
immédiatement mise en cause on a envie
de dire ça suffit
et puis cette occasion que l'ensemble de
la représentation nationale réaffirme
une fois de plus notre soutien à nos
forces de sécurité dans la solitude la
tristesse la privation de contact avec
les proches sont aussi des poisons
mortels
hier le chiffre de sept mille sept cent
cinquante deux personnes décédées dans
les ehpad de notre pays a été donné se
pose également toujours j'en terminerai
par là la question lancinante des tests
de dépistage encore suffisent
insuffisamment pratiqués pour les
résidents pour les personnels pour le ou
les membres des familles autorisés à
pénétrer dans les établissements pour
redémarrer le pays a besoin de se sentir
en confiance
or le déconfinement sanitaire est
aujourd'hui encore un grand texte à
trous avec moins de 1% de la population
tester nous continuons d'être à la
traîne des pays européens en matière de
tests
ils sont pourtant massivement nécessaire
au confinement sélectif des personnes à
risque et un éventuel dispositif
technologique de cartographie de
l'épidémie question simple et elles
seront ils disponibles et pour qui
[Musique]